also es gibt jetzt eine man muss sagen
das
hängt voll angesagt
ich traue mich zu bewegen weil die jacke
soll
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es von mir
frühstücks rezept ich hab mich vorhin
auf instagram gefragt was möchtet ihr
dieses jahr also 2022 vorgesehen und die
erste antwort die von euch rein kam ist
diese hier frühstücks rezepte also habe
ich mir gedacht ich zeige euch so meine
top 3 frühstücks rezepte die aber auch
gesunde ist weil ich versuche natürlich
auch immer gesund in den tag zu starten
und rezeptor bzw frühstücks ideen zu
zeigen die lange satt halten wir starten
jetzt mit porridge das habe ich erst
kürzlich so ein bisschen für mich
entdeckt weil ich von college immer so
langweilig geschmacklich war das
irgendwie nicht meins arbeiten muss
sagen wenn man das richtig macht und
auch richtig kommt dann kann das so
richtig lecker schmecken und hamza ist
voll der fan davon und ich starte jetzt
direkt ich mag dazu am liebsten
haferflocken mit großem blatt dann ist
er nämlich nicht so schlimm ich der
porridge bzw haferschleim eigentlich
aber auf englisch dass sich neues besser
an dann gebe ich immer eine mischung aus
hafer milch und wasser dazu können auch
nur wasser nehmen aber wenn ihr habe
mich nimmt oder andere mich dann wird es
einfach noch mal ein bisschen cremiger
so dann einfach mit dazu geben dem herd
einschalten und dann eindecken lassen
ich nehme da immer stufe sieben oder
acht von neun und das dauert ungefähr
zwei bis drei minuten
[Musik]
ihr könnt euren polizei noch verfeinern
ich habe zum beispiel noch eine prise
salz und wann in der extrakt dazu
gegeben und jetzt habe ich hier eine
volle schale ich habe hier die kokosnuss
schalen kleiner tipp wenn jemand die
kosten scheinen verwendet dann lasst
gern in pohritzsch fünf minuten
ausdampfen und nicht ganz so heiß hier
rein geben und da gewählt einfach nur
top ins mit dazu also da könnt ihr alles
mögliche nehmen worauf ihr lust habt ich
bin entweder frische früchte oder die
gefriergetrockneten die zog ich mir noch
mal so ein bisschen zusammen und macht
sie ein bisschen kleiner und dann kommen
auf jeden fall noch müsste dazu ich
brauche halt immer noch so ein quatsch
wobei ich sagen muss dieses porridge
wirklich der hammer verspeisen und der
liegt ja auch habe müsse über alles die
habe ich vorher einfach nur noch fein
gehackt und was ich auch noch gleich mit
dazu hebel sind kokosraspeln bei den
kokosraspeln hatte ich auch von meiner
raffaello torte die gerüsteten übrig und
geröstet schmecken die noch mal anders
geil müsste einfach mal ausprobieren und
dann müsst euch überlegen dass wir oben
drüber noch irgendein geniale stopping
in form von einer creme dazu ist ihr
könnt bist a ziehen muss oder erdnuss
muss oder socken ja so ein bisschen oder
was ich mache euch was
und wir können uns immer die kokons
gremium darauf gebe ich dann immer kurz
in die mikrowelle für 20 sekunden oder
15 sekunden und dann einfach drüber ist
ich heiser und dann einfach drüber
das wird so sein lassen
wieso haben sie das dass du gleich
verspeisen
ein bisschen mehr hast du ein bisschen
auf der linken seite prächtig muss
stimmen ja daraus natürlich recht dass
er jetzt so und dann einfach rein
schaufeln
[Musik]
also es gibt jetzt eine macht es gibt
es gibt es eine paul stoll wie es
eigentlich so fast jeden morgen und dann
kannst du den test machen und kritisch
beurteilen wie sie die schmeckt aber ich
hoffe du sagst ein gutes recht machen
sie also dreimal die woche also muss es
ja öfters und deswegen war ich das ja
auch aber ich muss sagen ich kämpfe mich
immer so durch und durch geht warum also
es stimmt haben sagt kritisiert nicht
bei einer sache immer und zwar sagt der
geschichte doch machtpolitisch da machst
ein bisschen kokos kriegen dann machst
du bist du dann wieder beugt habe ich
immer zu faul dafür morgens ich mal
einfach baut sondern alles andere aber
so geschmeckt mega lecker aber damit der
kredit ist einfach so abschließt hätte
ich das lange war ehrlich es geht so
ich hätte das auch nicht also gehe ich
jetzt selbst das klappt und man sagt ja
immer projekt langer sagt er werde ich
nicht so
lange
diese bull gut also dass weizen reis
meine mutter gemacht das hält
vorangebracht das hängt voll angesagt
aber es hätte
also ich bin damit immer so viel stunden
ungefähr sagt machte schon krieg hunger
und unbehandelt nach zwei stunden das
ist so dass man sich sagt wiemann bitter
sagt und man fühlt sich so ja das stimmt
aber ist die noch lustige haben wir
gemacht wir sind zwei schaufeln bringen
da kommen als ich auch noch mit aber ich
werde aus dieser raspel mikrochips die
partner
heute die rede ich mach frühstück
als nächstes machen wir eine web mit
eiern und dafür nehme ich mir einfach
zwei eier und schlagen wir einmal in
einer schüssel auf verquere die
miteinander
und dann gebe ich etwas öl in einer
pfanne könnte entweder ganz normal
sonnenblumenöl im kokosfett oder ihr
sprüht ich habe hier meinen olivenöl
spray ich habe auch die knoblauch
variante also wenn ihr an dem tag keine
mehr trefft ihr könnt auch die knoblauch
variante nehmen euch mit ihr das ganz
normale und früher das da rein damit
auch nicht zu fettig ist so könnte das
heißt super dosieren und dann wird erst
mal sozusagen 1 1 homenet gemacht und
dann zeige ich euch wieder zur app
direkt zum einsatz kommt
[Musik]
das augenlicht dann einmal umdrehen und
würzen ich habe dafür meinen royal
gewürz genommen rap oben drauf und dann
das ganze nochmal umdrehen
jetzt konnte nämlich mein rap auch von
der einen seite noch mal ein bisschen
brauner werden woche immer nur so 10 15
sekunden und ihr könnt ihr auch gerne
also ich habe jetzt ein protein rap
findet ihr manchmal auch als aktion in
supermärkten ich weiß gar nicht ob bei
kaufland ist es sogar dauerhaft ich bin
mir aber gar nicht sicher ich gebe da
jetzt einfach noch mal so ein bisschen
salat obendrüber ein bisschen rote
paprika und einfach eure lieblings soße
ich hab da letztens beim asiaten tonnen
katze mitgenommen hat sich lecker
angehört die gebe ich jetzt oben drauf
und da wird es eingeräumt
[Musik]
kombi ziffer 3 es wird wieder süß und
sehr fruchtig ihr könnt mir gerne mal in
die kommentare schreiben op-team süß
oder herzhaft morgens seit ich mache
jetzt eine smoothie bar dafür habe ich
hier ihr könnt irgendwelche tief
gefrorenen früchten ich nehme jetzt im
meer ich bin eigentlich immer das was
ich gerade da habe es geht auch zum
beispiel mango asahi ich habe ja auch
auf pulver im shop aber es gibt ja auch
mittlerweile tiefgefrorenes als püree
hier habe ich noch bananen die habe ich
in so stücke geschnitten und zuvor tief
gefroren auch ganz wichtig dass wir die
tiefe
tiefgefrieren auf jeden fall könnt ihr
das immer machen wenn ihr bananen übrig
habt und ihr merkt die werden total
braun wir können nicht mehr essen immer
in den tiefkühler und jetzt wird alles
erst mal püriert und dann gehen wir
schluckweise hafer milch mit dazu können
aber auch normale milch nimmt also alles
was ihr möchtet
[Musik]
das ganze wird dann einfach nur püriert
und ja auch bei hochpreisigen mixern
würde ich jetzt behaupten muss man es
immer unter schauen wir sind kein mixa
der wirklich eine smoothie ball auf
knopfdruck richtig schön kuriert ich
musste selber jetzt 89 mal das ganze
herunter schrauben und nochmal pürieren
lassen und da gebe ich jetzt einfach nur
noch schöne toppings drauf zum beispiel
kakao nebst mond wenn ihr möchtet
frische früchte oder getrocknete früchte
und das ist aber auch etwas was jetzt
nicht irgendwie vorbereiten können also
ihr macht das im mixer und dann müsst
ihr das quasi sofort verspeisen weil es
ist ja so halb gefroren ich jetzt
behaupten dadurch dass man mit der zeit
auch noch mal ein bisschen wärmer und
das müsste dann quasi direkt verspeisen
[Musik]
haben sie richtig nett von dir dazu
eigentlich ja kassen gehen wollt ist
aber trotzdem auch hier bis zum thema
rechnet könnt ihr kommentare schreiben
und ich bin er schaue nicht so ich will
das leben was das ist eine smoothie ball
war wenn ihr motive na ja das ist so
schon am morgen noch weniger zu sehen
möchte ohne bananen zum beispiel
schreibe mal die kommentare soll ich mal
so top 3 fuhr sie rezepte für euch
machen dass er die folgen ist es sommer
zurückholen wollen du willst sein sollen
liegen oder sowas genießen dann gibt man
ranking ich bin ehrlich ich bin kein
frühstück ich muss jetzt sich jeden tag
essen aber einmal die woche geht doch
immer klar vereins zehnten 8,5 also nur
weil ich nach meinem geschmack
einstellen also wenn ich jetzt richtig
liebe würde ich natürlich zum verteilen
also fast zum beispiel porsches zu
kalorienreich findet finde ich
persönlich nicht aber ihr könnt das als
kalorienärmere variante nehmen und es
ist halt wirklich super erfrischend ne
also vielleicht auch morgens und nach
dem workout oder so stelle ich mir das
auch richtig gut vor so ich wünsche euch
auf jeden fall viel freude bei der
polizei in die kommentare welches rezept
ihrem besten pandit und ob ihr jetzt so
ein neuer auch irgendwie neujahrsvorsatz
verhaftet
aber ich muss sagen auch wenn wir hier
traf man gleich drehe ich eine leckere
masse gegend ortet auch davon müssen wir
immer noch ein stück und alles gut
so schlank aus
und sagen bis zum nächsten mal auf die
kisten ist voll motiviert
ich habe angst genau
[Musik]
[Applaus]